he asked me if I had ever worked for a
terrible
leader
and I said that you know I had so he
leaned over and got a piece of paper and
he slid it across the desk because it's
rather fine Phantom pen and asked me to
write down a list of what does dreadful
leadership look like right welcome to 20
minute leaders just sit back relax and
learn from the leaders of today it's a
journey each one is different unique
inspiring let's get started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
today we're talking to Antonio garrido
he has over 25 years of in senior
leadership positions with world-class
businesses he is an expert in leadership
transformation shaping high performance
leaders out of Highly stressed and
overworked leaders garrido Blends his
own vast commercial experience with
proven techniques to embed a unique
brand of leadership development he is a
Serial entrepreneur successful business
coach author charismatic speaker and
works with leaders from small private
businesses right up to Fortune 60 size
it currently resides in France
[Music]
foreign
welcome to 20 minute leaders thank you
so much for joining me all the way from
beautiful beautiful friends how are you
I'm terribly well thank you Michael and
I really do that was a very good uh
pronunciation of the name and thank you
very much for your kind invitation I do
love your podcast so um well thank you I
really appreciate it and I've been
practicing the last name as you know
um really it's um this is exactly why I
do this show these for these
conversations about leadership what does
it take to be a good leader what what
does it mean even to be a good leader
um you're the founder and president of
my daily leadership you're working with
leaders across the board
um all sorts of sizes of companies and
so
um I'm excited to learn as much as
possible thank you again for being here
very good let's let's see what we can
learn together perhaps how's that
wonderful well your interest in
leadership let's start from there where
does that stem from for you
oh gosh that's a great question I think
um
I guess like most of your viewers uh
subscribers listeners
we've probably
we've probably all worked for some
exceptional leaders let's start on the
good side of the coin hopefully probably
all worth on really inspirational
uh really transformative
developmental Solutions oriented great
individuals right the good guys
um but then maybe some of us are also
unfortunate enough to have worked for
some
less gifted less talented leaders shall
we say
um I've been incredibly fortunate to
have worked for some outstanding leaders
and
um I'm incredibly old as you can imagine
and over the years uh when I first
joined the world of work I was fortunate
to have some uh tremendous leaders and
then some not so good and I started to
do a compare and contrast maybe 20 odd
years ago
um I've always always believed that and
wisdom comes from evaluated experience
right it it's not as a consequence of
time served and I've always also
believed that the only Advantage we have
today over yesterday is what we've
learned I mean unless you've amassed
some great wealth through the last 24
hours right it's about what have you
learned so I've always
tried to keep a very open mind to
learning opportunities that not only in
in myself and my people but also looking
up and across the organization not just
kind of down and across but also up
um
and when I eventually got to a position
of leadership
um I really tried hard to apply all the
best characteristics of the good guys
um and uh really tried hard to avoid the
the Dreadful ones I can give you a
tremendous exercise for that uh for your
uh
um subscribers if they're interested you
know if you're interested in that
they're interested in that of course of
course yes there's a very enlightening
exercise for that
um so then I became
um
um a a a a coach
um a trainer um
um a business development uh manager
actually I guess before that you know I
did a lot of consultancy I did
consultancy for the National Health
Service in the UK which is actually the
largest company in the world people
don't recognize
um they're actually bigger than the
Chinese Army but that's a whole
conversation for another day so I did
lots
um interim
um consultancy
um kind of being business doctor being
parachuted into I don't say failing com
let's say stressed companies and and
turning them around and then looking for
my replacement right looking for the
permanent person to come and replace me
and I never really wanted that to be me
um I wrote a couple of books and then I
wrote uh this book which I've kind of
been writing for 20 years which is all
about
um you know what do the best what are
the what separates Great from good in
terms of leadership and then how can we
how can we help how can we help the good
leaders that want to become great
leaders you know those that recognize
that they're not the finished article
right that they're not I mean we all
know that none of us are perfect right
so okay so we get that
um I read in Bill Clinton's uh
autobiography where he talked about you
know the best you can do is hope to make
seven out of ten good decisions right
because you're dealing with some really
really tricky stuff if you're the
president of the United States and I
thought is that good enough it's seven
out of ten good enough right
um maybe if you're deciding what to do
with the Israelis and Palestine
um security here the the state you know
maybe seven out of ten is good enough
but I thought you know I I'm not sure
that's a high enough aspiration for
leadership of companies who are trying
to trying to
make the kinds of decisions that will
future proof themselves their people and
their business because that's their job
right and I thought well seven out of
ten seems okay but it seems like a
slightly low bar so how can we help
people do even better than that no one's
going to be perfect but kind of raise
the odds a little bit and there's a big
difference between 7 out of ten and nine
out of ten you know in terms of decision
making so I kind of put all of that
together in this book
um and we put together a you know a
leadership development program which we
can kind of talk about later but should
I come back to that exercise I was going
to mention earlier would that be a good
yes yeah I was about to ask for that
yeah so you'll notice that I just go off
on tangents I I don't and they're great
go for it go for it it's straight lines
well this was a this was a a lesson the
I was taught by one of my first ever
leaders I had been given a fairly senior
role in an organization and honestly I
wasn't ready for it I was kind of
punching above my weight but it was kind
of circumstances and
I was the right person for the job kind
of politically but I'm not sure I was
entirely the right person for the job
um
um in terms of capability
but anyways
um fact of the matter is I got the job
and this leader who was tremendous
tremendous tremendous chairman asked me
to uh pop pop along to his office
um I uh
I found a handwritten note on my desk
this is I I'm telling you I'm absolutely
ancient Michael so this was before email
all that kind of stuff right there was a
note on my desks that asked me to pop
along to the chairman so I popped along
there
and uh uh he you know we sat down across
his rather Grand and imperious looking
desk and he asked me if I had ever
worked for
um a terrible
leader
um and I said that you know I had so he
uh leaned over and got a piece of paper
and he slid it across the desk with his
rather fine Phantom pen and asked me to
write down a list of what does dreadful
leadership look like right and I wrote
four or five things and your you know
subscribers can easily imagine what they
might look like right somebody that
micromanages somebody that plays
favorites somebody that
um uh
uh instruct somebody that
um
uh is very
um let's say
you know blows hot and cold inconsistent
somebody that makes yeah
everybody else you know externalizes
other issues all of that stuff right we
all know what treadful looks like so I
wrote four or five things and slid that
piece of paper back and he said terrific
write some more so I wrote some more
things and again you can imagine what
they might be and just developed people
doesn't develop themselves it's very
tactical not strategic doesn't live the
vision
uh ineffective and
all of those kind of things he said
terrific right answer more I'm thinking
crikey so I'm stuck to kind of scrape
the bottom of the barrel anyway I came
out with some more things and if any of
your leader um leaders or listeners want
to play that game write down about 20
things so I got down to about 20 things
and I looked at it he said that's right
that's exactly right that's what
Dreadful leadership is I couldn't have
put it but myself terrific thought ties
strange exercise he then passed a piece
of paperback and they said you do me a
big favor so I said yeah he said whilst
Debbie you're working here can you
promise to never do any of these things
right well Stephie you are here I said
yeah okay and he said now carry that
piece of paper with you at all times I
every time I see you in the corridor I
might want to talk to you about your
list
and so he he had us all imagine oh by
the way I then discovered about three
months later that he did the same
exercise with every single board member
right because we all have a vision of
great we all have a vision of dreadful
and so we were all constantly so cool oh
so cool so then anytime anything went
wrong right because things do
um at the board meeting the chairman
would come in and and ask us all get out
our pieces of paper and say where is it
that we've failed such that this thing
has happened right or this thing has
materialized so
so that got me started on this PR this
this principle of evaluated experience
on this principle that none of us are
perfect none of us are great let's start
to think on a really really
consistent basis how could I do better
right what's my leadership report card
for today
um it's not going to be a plus every day
because it just can't be and so there
are days when it's going to be a minus
or a B plus or even a B minus and then
we either just kind of say well hey such
is life nobody's perfect that's it or we
say well that's not good enough right so
what should or could I have done or what
should I not have done or if I had my
time to live the day it's kind of
Groundhog Day right so I had the
opportunity to do it all again what
would I do more of or less of or or
whatever
um and that principle then led to you
know there should be a we should be able
to record all of these things
um I then is this useful by the way are
you okay for
so I gave a talk
um a few years ago to maybe four or five
hundred liters and I gave the talk and I
said okay chaps and by the way chaps is
you know that's kind of like and you
know that could be anything right so I
said uh okay chaps uh honesty time right
let's just all have a real
good bite of reality sandwich who here
which would lead us here
um could a show of hands please who has
some leadership blind spots okay and
thankfully every single hand in the
audience went up look thankfully because
actually yeah
that's not always the case but this is a
good Bunch right so everybody put their
hands up recognizing that they all had
leadership blind spots terrific today
just take a minute now if you would and
write down what they are right so and
now here's the thing
we don't know what they are because if
we knew what they were then it's a blind
spot right if we knew what those blind
spots were they wouldn't be black yeah I
yeah I guess it was a contrivance it was
just like trick question just to get
them to realize oh crikey I must have
some blind spots I have no idea what
they might be and so if if leaders
responsibility is to Future proof
themselves
future proof their business future proof
their business uh their people and their
business then they have to first kind of
recognize well where are their
weaknesses where where do they come on
that list right and it's interesting
isn't it but
most people they kind of think they're a
good driver right in my experience when
you say when you ask people are you a
good driver most people say oh yeah way
above average what a hundred percent of
people can't be above average right just
the math doesn't work most leaders when
you talk to them you say where are you
on the leadership scale from kind of you
know Dreadful to rock star right they
always go oh yeah I'm towards the good
end of the scale it's okay terrific
um and where are these weaknesses yeah
well it's difficult to say and I don't
know and the problem is nobody tells
them no one comes into their office and
goes tap tap tap on the door you've got
five minutes boss they go yeah you know
my doors always open to you and then
they sit down okay well thanks for that
um I just thought I'd spend 20 minutes
with you telling you how hurtful you've
been over the last six months I mean
that doesn't happen right but where does
it happen very often and um and asking
people to do that hey guys you know me I
I'm always open the door's always open
and you know um if ever you feel
that you know I'm not doing such a
tremendous job come and tell me which is
a bit like saying hey can all the
turkeys vote for Thanksgiving please and
turkeys tend not to want to vote for
Thanksgiving so they don't tend to do
that I saw a church
a tremendous um kind of
tiny interview with uh George Bush or
ex-President Bush you know the Elder one
golf tournament
they still call him Mr President even
though he's kind of ex-president and
somebody stuck a camera in his faces it
came off the 18th degree green it was no
he hadn't been the president for about
five or six years and
um somebody as I said this reporter
stuck a camera in his face and said how
was the goal for Mr President
and he thought for a second and he said
probably what I think is the smartest
thing that he's ever said and he said
it's amazing how many games of golf he's
lost since not being the president of
the United States and I thought well
that's wow
you're the president of the United
States you somehow your golf's improved
somehow right
not sure that's entirely true so anyway
I was putting together all of these
things and I thought you know
do you know what everybody what all
leaders should do you know if they want
to raise their self-awareness and if
they want to if they want to figure out
if wisdom does come about from evaluated
experience where are they going to keep
a record of all of this how they're
going to evaluate their experience how
how they're going to get people to be
more collaborative including themselves
and then what would the best Leadership
Model look like and I was putting all of
this stuff together and I thought to
myself you know what I tell you what I'm
going to do I'm gonna I'm going to jump
on
um
uh you know uh Google there are other
search engines available of course and
uh and and find
um a leadership Journal right some kind
of place where you know there's journals
for everything right and and there
wasn't one or there was a couple but I
mean just too dreadful for words so I
thought you know let's let's put
together
um a a journal
um for leaders the covers
specifically these principles of insight
and wisdom and
um
[Music]
if if you ask lots of leaders or even
individuals and you say to people Hey
listen what does success look like to
you right and then you get a whole range
of answers between
um money some people say
um which kind of leads you know it boils
down to if I can die with lots of toys I
win so there's that as a kind of
principle
um other people say it's kind of
reaching their goals which I also don't
subscribe to
um for me I think leadership or success
rather is reaching your maximum
potential whatever that is now not
everyone can reach their maximum
potential
um and I think but if you can figure out
how to reach your maximum potential then
then that's what success would look like
now there are some people who are here
right let's say and sorry their maximum
potential is here and they're down here
and and then there is a big Delta
there's a big gap between where they are
and where they could be and that kind of
leads to dissatisfaction and feelings of
frustration and so on and then there are
other people whose maximum potentials
here and there right here and therefore
they feel fulfilled and happy and you
know it you don't have to be the leader
of you know a fortune 60 uh organization
to feel fulfilled to feel that you know
you are there there or thereabouts and
you look at a lot of leaders and you
think look at all the things that you've
achieved and they're still unhappy
because they're right right money or
fame but they're unhappy because they
feel that they could that there's still
a gap between where they are and where
you know where they could be where their
potential is so anyway
putting all of these things together
um and I put you know I I built this
model of leadership development based on
self-awareness based on
um uh a Leadership Model that most
leadership models are are kind of
they're based on
some but not all of what great
leadership is about so so so what's
great leadership about well it's about
it's about developing people so it's
people development which is a tricky
thing right that's helping others reach
their full potential it's about being
great mentors very misunderstood
principle with most leaders they think
that mentorship is coaching and it's not
the same thing
um understanding people's motivation
they seem to forget
the Rope who wants right that that other
people come to work for different
reasons to themselves right they they
come most people come to work because
you know maybe they've got a mortgage
and the kids need some shoes on their
feet but whilst the leadership team come
to work because they've made promises to
the city and so who knows right so we've
got this people development thing
um also mostly good leaders are good at
communicating and coordinating and and
having people cooperate but the best
leaders are really really good at
encouraging a culture of collaboration
if you ever take the time to look at how
Lego was saved it's an amazing story of
collaboration anyway so we have this
people development model and then so and
also then company development what most
leaders the good ones they think about
company development they just think you
know short medium and long-term plans
right and planning but you know it's
more than that because it's also
developing the vision mission goals it's
improving company processes and it's
also making the the hardest decision
about
do we industrialize scale pivot refresh
what do we do about these kind of things
that are maybe a little bit broken so
there's some company development stuff
too and the the journaling process and
the the the
program that we've put together deals
with all of these things and then this
self-development because do you know
what I find quite amazing how many
organizations I've been into and I've
said tell me about you know personal
development reviews and all of that kind
of stuff with your organization and the
enlightened ones say oh yeah we have one
every quarter and we do them and we live
them and not nothing to do with you know
salary it's not a salary
um uh issue it really is helping out
people develop and the role on
development plans and that we don't just
put them in a drawer once a year and
then kind of forget them I say oh
terrific can I see yours and then they
go uh uh right kind of Shuffle around
look at that feature well they you know
they kind of don't walk that talk don't
walk that yeah they don't walk that talk
so it's about what's their own personal
learning path what's their where are
their leadership blind spots that we
talked about building their own
emotional intelligence and also solving
problems with tools and mental models as
opposed to just relying on their
experience right
so anyway whole conversation about tools
and mental models really I mean I don't
know I have to say that this is so uh so
incredible because I think that at the
end first of all I need to book you for
for another episode because we're just
getting started and I think this needs
to be a series a series on leadership
but I think
I think that what you I think that what
you touched on you know it's you know
we're talking about you know leaders of
large companies or any size companies
but really we're talking about
leadership in life right and when we're
talking about maximizing potential or or
reaching or sort of aiming for Maslow's
hierarchy of needs and sort of the
self-fulfillment you know anybody's
everybody has different potential and
really that's where you get the
satisfaction from the Fulfillment from
reaching our potential otherwise if you
have that Gap you feel dissatisfied and
it sounds like this exercise that you're
talking about the sort of there I see
two sides to it one is sort of
identifying what what is important for
you as a leader or where you might go
astray from personal experiences and and
improving on those but really it's that
Improvement aspect what did I learn to
become better and how do I make sure
that I'm creating an environment of
accountability which which I'm both
allowing myself to be open to it but
also allowing others to provide me that
that feedback so Antonio really just
just really incredible conversation
thank you so much I'm we're already
scheduling again because I need to
continue exactly from where we left off
we're gonna have to stay true to the
format and so I really really appreciate
your time and this was just so inspiring
good
I've enjoyed it I'm sorry if I just kind
of rambled on but I just got a lot to
say so bring me back and it was I I
didn't want to stop it it was wonderful
thank you so so much